hello and welcome to this
video playing nikolai posh2 cough
i already have lost two games against
this guy
don't remember how where when why hope
to do better now
so playing this um
ready setup like a slav without
slav without um deform
okay i have really forgotten i checked
this briefly but i have forgotten this
how it is actually played
and it doesn't seem right i had to
insert
this h3 right so that g4 now would have
been a move
okay now i'm i think i'm i'm still
getting there because the d5
pawn is now tender and should
drop so i go back
but does he have b4 yeah he claims to
have b4 here in this position
so okay
moving the knight looks odd so
if i take it it's also looks odd
anyway so let's take
take g7 or
g7
yeah i can take with the queen bishop
takes queen d5
with unclear consequences bishop takes
bishop g7 is not
as clear what the benefit is so here i'm
i have won a pawn
i don't know if the position is good
though just
tough to um tough to figure out
i tried to immediately okay so he
doesn't mind a queen trade which
i will agree on
knight e4 is his idea to get
everything active
it's a bit strange to move that again
but it's difficult to develop and i need
to use the pieces that i have in play
i think trying to disturb him knight e4
i'm going to take g6 play bishop f3
so that doesn't seem to work
and if you move the bishop i have rook
g1
okay this i'm taking bishop f3
and my development is lacking badly but
i can just use what i have and
get get somewhere so
i can actually cover
i can cover this right
rook b4 fb3 and
possibly
bishop d2 coming
this is staying weak that's my point
the e4 bond so a3
king f5 i have a check that's a blunder
i have to be fast though i'm
seriously behind on the on the clock
yeah it's a very good end game though
maybe not the best technique possible
but
it is a lot better for me
[Music]
just trying to
simplify the position
going to that weak pawn on d6
it's amazing how much time i'm down
and he's not doing anything special but
he's doing it quickly
should be able to trade rook now no
yeah this is not bad not good
in my quest of making it easy for me i
i have given up a pawn
that would be a draw he will not do that
ever
people like that will always flag
because that's their main way of winning
games
i know i'm actually blundering the rook
yeah okay
[Music]
i was just by far too slow i haven't
adjusted to the time control
the game itself was just yeah what what
what i don't know just i'm just much
better
and and should win but i didn't
the opening was a little bit odd and
here
there is compensation for black for sure
but
the way he played it it was pretty much
nothing
like here this is still probably
compensation but 94
is just a bad move i think it should
just um
be good for me knight c6 is also good
actually
that's a very tactical way of doing it
like this
and now h5 bishop f5 knight d4
the bishop has no squares
yeah but okay this was um
in particularly particularly helpful
because i have
i didn't have much time and while this
is
maybe equal with perfect play it's just
easy for me to do
so yeah he was just quick
the whole time he was playing fast and
i'm i wasn't quite speeding up all that
much
um yeah i tried to
be somewhat fast and was happy to return
some material i mean
it's really not worth looking at because
it's it's just totally winning but i
have 12 seconds that that was
awful yeah i'm difficult to adjust yeah
um i have to really also find some
solution here for those
daily blitz games switching the time is
tricky i think
it's really tricky um because i had
those slower games
before and now i have three zero um
that's tricky really i wonder what the
best um
approach is
having the increment games is not bad
for quality
but they are somewhat slowish and
the main games that i play like in
tournaments is non-increment and faster
so having 3-0 as a more regular time
control is not bad and i'm not terrible
at that
but i just have to get into that mode
and it's not so easy to do commentary
for them
as we as we see i'm kind of too slow i
mean
it was totally idiotic to be so much
down on the clock by move 19
yeah that is just yeah then you lose
even games like that where black was
just
basically playing for time from the
get-go
alright thanks for watching